when I first started treasure hunting
I'll come down to the river pretty much
every single day and I'll surf and wrap
and have a good time at the river for
the first time I went underneath the
water I just open my eyes to a world I
didn't know existed my name is Jake
wholly I'm a free diver and treasure
hunter still man on dive Anna
Chattahoochee River in Columbus Georgia
which is one of the world's largest
urban whitewater courses ever built so
this is actually Georgia and the other
side the river is Alabama thousands of
people go down this river every single
year and they leaves all kinds of
valuables and it's a lot of fun to go
out there and swim and see if I can find
some stuff they lost some of my most
interesting things I found definitely
have to be like iPhones GoPros pistols
[Music]
always pretty interesting to find like a
potential murder weapon out here in a
river but GoPros and in phones
definitely my favorite finds when I find
these cameras and phones I try to just
figure out who it belongs to because not
only like fun and this stuff is a lot of
fun but giving back the devices that
they've lost is also a blast becoming be
careful out here oh well not only you
find a lot of cool stuff that people
lose after rafting but thousands upon
thousands of fishermen come up here and
normally no one would go out there and
collect all these fishing lures but I go
out there and I'll free him from the
wall I'm freeing from the stumps and it
just kind of cleans up the area and I
get free fishing lures there's a lot of
animals underneath the water you got a
lot of striped bass shad spotted bass
and catfish you see a lot of turtles
down here too if she's just super
beautiful to see all that stuff first
day back to Jake finds a GoPro he was
diving right next I was really surprised
how many people were interested in
watching treasure hunting videos today
hey we got another fan over there I love
coming down here look for treasure and
surfing and having a good time but I
didn't know I can actually do this as
like a full-time job I started my
youtube channel and record myself
swimming and having a good time at the
river and one thing led to another and
now I'm able to do this is I'm a
full-time job more
[Applause]
[Music]
the more I travel the more I realize
that this spot is actually one-of-a-kind
there's that many places in the world
that you can actually surf at a river
you know you get fish and treasure hunt
I have a love for this river man and I
just can't stay inside I have to go down
and have a good time
you